for me
joking about suicide is not something
that i do uh on the show
and i am not someone who says here's a
list of topics you can never joke about
but on this program we we do sometimes
joke about things but i don't joke about
suicide
uh and it makes it all the more
um
interesting
that the ukrainian ambassador to the
united nations sergey
yesterday said in a serious way again
without joking about suicide if putin
wants to end up dead
he should just shoot himself dead the
way hitler did in the bunker in 1945 and
the point here
is actually it's not a joke it's if for
whatever reason putin has a death wish
the desire to destroy
reckless uh
reckless desires which could lead to him
ending up dead
don't
kill other people just kill yourself and
that's me paraphrasing let's listen to
sergey kislytsia yesterday to the united
nations we have been prompted to call
for an emergency special session as the
level of the threat to the global
security has been equated to the to that
of the second world war
or even higher following
putin's order to put an alert russian
nuclear forces what what a madness
if he wants to kill himself
he doesn't need to use nuclear arsenal
he has to do what he's saying what what
the guy in in berlin did in the bunker
in may
1945. so of course he's referring to
hitler taking his own life and i think
there is a point here that is a good one
if vladimir putin has a death wish if he
wants to blow everything up proverbially
as much as literally and end up dead
potentially he could just take himself
out and not as many other people i don't
think this is a joke about suicide it's
not a question of encouraging suicide or
any of it the sentiment that comes
through here is if you're determined to
ruin your own life why do you have to
ruin so many others as well i was
watching video on argentinian television
this morning
they have correspondence on the border
between ukraine and poland and to see
the looks of shock on people's faces as
they flee ukraine some literally unable
to speak for periods of time
from the shock that they are
experiencing you you don't have to ruin
other people's lives if you're simply
determined to ruin your own now to some
degree
i would bet anything i have
that the topic of assassinating putin
has come up at the top levels of
government i'm not saying anyone's
thinking of doing it i'm not saying
anyone plans to do it or would do it but
without a doubt
when aids are supposed to present all
options to world leaders
it is impossible to imagine that they
are coming forward and saying okay we
can send weapons we could send troops we
could look at drones we can do this we
can do that
here's what it would look like if we
tried to assassinate putin it's clearly
being mentioned by the people who were
paid to present all options to world
leaders i don't believe it's being
seriously considered i don't believe
it's going to be done and i'm not
suggesting it be done but the point here
from the ukrainian ambassador once again
is
not everybody has to suffer because
putin has become a reckless tyrant and
uh that certainly is coming through in
the desperation
of the voice of the ambassador from
ukraine to the united nations